hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the most Central points that
Seneca is making in his work on the
shortness of life is indeed not just
that life is short but that time is
something that we typically don't value
as we should and if we understood things
rightly we would see that time is the
most precious thing of all for a number
of reasons and I think the place to
begin
in this work is in chapter three where
he uh starts it by saying though all the
Brilliant Minds that have shown over the
ages agree on this one point they could
never adequately Express their
astonishment at this dark fog in the
human mind calignon is is fog or smoke
or obscurity there and then mentium in
human Minds No One lets anyone seize
their estate so property is something
that we value and protect if a dispute
arises about boundary lines there's a
rush to arms but people that others
trespass on their existence and by this
he doesn't mean you know threaten their
life as such because we do respond to
that but the day-to-day living we let
people cross over and take part of what
belongs to us he said rather they go so
far as to invite in those who will take
possession of their lives
you'll find no one willing to distribute
his money but how many people to how
many people each of us shares out his
life in drips and drabs we give portions
of our very existence to other people
people who we wouldn't give a dime to
you know or let alone a dollar or a
large amount of money and he says people
are thrifty in guarding their private
property but as soon as it comes to
wasting time they're most extravagant
with the one commodity for which it's
respectable to be greedy so you
shouldn't be greedy with your property
with your wealth you should have the
right attitude towards that
but you should be when it comes to time
why well to begin with it's continually
dripping away you're never gonna get it
back well maybe you will we'll get to
that in in a moment the way in which
that's possible but you're never going
to get your life back you're always
moving forward into a future in which
your death is approaching you and it
could be tomorrow that's going to happen
or it could be years from now but you
know you spend those years and then it
becomes tomorrow so if we jump ahead to
chapter eight where he discusses this at
greater length he says
I'm astonished when I see people
requesting the time of others
and receiving an accommodating response
from those who they approach why both
sides focus on the object of the request
and neither on time itself so we think
oh you know I'm being asked to do this
thing for somebody I'm being asked to
give my time to this particular activity
over here to help somebody out right and
we don't think of it in terms of the
time itself which is what they're really
asking us for and he'll go on and say
that people trifle with they make light
of the most precious commodity
right so does this really translate
necessarily as commodity no it could
just be the most precious thing the most
valuable thing in the world and he says
why do they do this well because it's
easy to focus on what's tangible the
things that we can actually
see the things that we can bring before
our eyes or at least successfully
imagine he says you know for example
people set very great store by annuities
and gratuities and for these they hire
out their services or efforts or
attentions people you know care about
property and and money and stuff like
that
but they don't do this with time why not
because time is immaterial it escapes
their notice because it's not something
that we can place right in front of
ourselves and you know we could say well
I can look at my calendar I can you know
set up a schedule I could like look back
at my old
Diaries or my journals or something like
that I can see the passage of time yes
that's all true but you can't see time
itself and yet you're in it you're
swimming in it you're moving forward in
it towards the future leaving the past
behind in this little thing that we call
the present and he goes on he says that
a lot of people
they value time as if it was worthless
they think they have plenty of it right
I've got time to spare as a matter of
fact later on he talks about other
people who are trying to as we say in
English kill time right they're trying
to while away the hours so they can get
to the thing that they want to he talks
about you know there's an announcement
about a gladiatorial show that's going
to be on and we can think about all
sorts of other things oh you know this
movie is going to be coming out I can't
wait people say and they try to figure
out how to burn away that time you know
back when I was in school I remember us
being bored a lot and being like when
will three o'clock come so we can get
out of here what can I do to take my
mind off of this boring thing that I'm
supposed to be listening to well that's
wasting time right and so he goes out
and he says that
no one values time I'll use it more than
lavishly as if it costs nothing now
that's the normal way of doing things
then he says when there's mortal danger
threatening us we get sick we're you
know on a ship that's bouncing around on
a stormy sea or pick whatever else it is
he says mortal danger threatens them
you'll see the same people clasping
their doctor's knees if they fear a
capital charge you'll see them ready to
spend all they have to stay alive
there's a great conflict in their
feelings or sentiments or ideas about
something so when crises hit suddenly
the time is valuable otherwise
not really
and He suggests that if we could
actually see time you know past and
future we would in fact act differently
if time was more tangible to us then you
know especially if we knew exactly how
much future we have left now we can make
projections and I'll just say as sort of
a side note on a personal level I am in
my 50s so I'm in middle age and I
remember how much time I wasted in my
teens and 20s and 30s and even in my 40s
right and when you turn 40 given a life
expectancy of maybe 80 years you're like
well
half my life is gone I've got maybe half
of it ahead of me I can still do a lot
of things when you get into your 50s now
you're definitely on the shorter side of
things Seneca himself is writing as an
older person about this and he's writing
to a friend who is preoccupied with his
job monitoring the granaries and imports
and stuff like that now back to this
right so if we could see time we would
act differently he also talks about this
funny phenomenon of wanting to bestow
our time on our loved ones and this
doesn't mean just like spending time
doing nice things for them he talks
about it in this way says
people will say to those they love most
intensely they are ready to give them
some of their own years as if you could
transfer time from one person to another
I will have 10 years less you will have
10 years more that doesn't work because
that doesn't that's not part of the
metaphysics of human nature we could say
but we can end up wasting our time he
says they do give them without knowing
it but they give in such a way without
adding to the years of their loved ones
they subtract from themselves and this
very Point namely whether they're
depriving themselves eludes them and so
they can bear the loss of what goes
unnoticed in the losing no one will
follow the PA no one will get bring back
the years no one will restore you to
your former self he says time the
passage of it causes no commotion at all
it will call no attention to its own
swiftness right so we really ought to
given these considerations value our
time much more highly and one way that
we can do this Seneca is going to
suggest this is something we'll talk
about more elsewhere
is by doing philosophy he tells us and
this is one of the most striking
passages in this work of all people they
alone who give their time to philosophy
are at leisure they alone truly live why
because it's not just their own lifetime
they watch over carefully they enacts
every age to their own all the years
that have gone before are added to their
own so whereas with our loved ones we
even if we want to we can't actually
give them some of our years
it is possible to receive years
from other people including other people
who are long dead and we do this by
making their time our time he calls this
the sole means of prolonging mortality
or transforming it into immortality
right and he talks about nature allowing
a shared possession of any age why don't
we
turn ourselves from this short and
fleeting passage of time and give
ourselves completely over to the past
which is measureless and eternal and
shared with our Bettors this is one of
the things we can do with philosophy and
he urges his friend at the end while
enthusiasm is still fresh
those with an act of Interest should
progress to better things in this mode
of Life much that is worth studying
awaits you what what is practicing
philosophy consistent love and practice
of the virtues forgetfulness of passions
knowledge of how to live and die and
deep Repose or rest so it is possible to
have more of this commodity
by so to speak borrowing or inheriting
from others who have given us the
possibility for this most people don't
do that most people Fritter away their
time and what erodes it is going to be
something that is the term that he uses
over and over and over again in this
piece which is typically translated in
English as being preoccupied the Latin
is ocupatus for you know a masculine
okupata for feminine and it means being
busy seed with things even if you're
being busied by enjoying the pleasures
that you've set up for yourself he tells
us that some people turn their very
Leisure into preoccupation and
preoccupation is the biggest thing he
says that robs us of our time right he
tells us days are present only one at a
time these only minute by minute all the
days of time past will attend you at
your bidding if you want but you have to
have a tranquil mind preoccupied people
can't do that preoccupied people can't
even adequately study arts or
disciplines and so you know what do
these these people do they take this
most valuable thing
and they value other things more highly
and they become preoccupied with them
and they lose all that time that they
had in the process so Seneca is
counseling us we really need to pay
attention to this all the time pun
intended there like every single day we
should be reminding ourselves that life
is short and it's too easy for us to
lose time in ways that are not making
good use of it and we're exchanging this
most precious commodity for all sorts of
other things that if they matter they
don't matter as much as our time